am Tag an dem die gaspreisbremse
verkündet wird geht es um großes man
kann sagen dass es hier ein doppeldons
Deutschland zeigt hier seine
wirtschaftliche Schlagkraft in einem
energiekrieg das ist die Gegenwehr heute
mit dem apfelschirmen die wir ergreifen
es geht darum nicht ganz so großes um
eine Koalition die nicht nur mit der
Energiekrise ringt sondern mit sich
selbst
ja
ganz schön weit auseinander findet habe
ich mit Blick auf Lindner und es passt
irgendwie das Scholz da noch nicht
zugeschaltet ist aus seiner
corona-quarantäne zwei Rivalen einer der
sich raushält der Streit ums Gas erzählt
viel über den Zustand dieser Koalition
damals bei der Verkündung der gasumlage
fliegt scheut sogar aus dem
allgäu-urlaub ein
you'll never walk alone
dass wir gemeinsam die schwierigen
Zeiten bewältigen dass wir
zusammenhalten dass es entscheidend von
zusammenhalten aber ist in der Ampel
bald nur noch wenig zu sehen die
gasumlage hat handwerkliche Fehler
belastet Bürger und die Koalition von
allen beschlossen wollen viele es nun
schon immer besser gewusst haben ich
finde nicht dass wir uns einen schlanken
Fuß gemacht haben es ist einfach so die
gasumlage ist mal mit Argumenten in die
Debatte eingeführt worden die bei
genauerer Betrachtung einfach keinen
Bestand hatten es ist ja auch mal vom
Minister als alternativlos bezeichnet
worden und natürlich gab es Alternativen
zur ungerechten gasumlage so bleibt die
an Habeck hängen seinen Absturz in der
Beliebtheit sehen die Koalitionspartner
mit stiller Genugtuung
besonders die FDP die bei der
anstehenden Wahl in Niedersachsen um den
Einzug ins Parlament fürchten muss für
den Straßenwahlkampf der Liberalen gilt
die gasumlage ist harbex Bock die
gaspreisbremse Lindners Lösung
die gaspreisbremse das war ja dann ein
Vorschlag von unserer Seite auch von
Christian Lindner weil wir gesagt haben
wir müssen direkt am Preis Ansetzen der
Preis muss direkt runter die gasumlage
von Robert Habeck hätte den Gaspreis
zunächst erhöht SPD und Grüne erzählen
die Geschichte ein bisschen anders
demnach wollte Lindner lange an der
gasumlage festhalten sie hätte seinen
Haushalt nicht belastet
am Montag wird Scholz positiv auf Corona
getestet die Verhandlungen mit den
Ministerpräsidenten lässt der vertagen
die metabic und Lindner führt der
Digital zwei Nächte lang wird gerungen
die SPD will für die gaspreisbremse an
die Mittel des Klimafonds die Grünen
sind strikt dagegen die FDP beharrt auf
der Schuldenbremse Einigung bringt ein
anderer Fond der für Wirtschaft
Stabilisierung gefüllt mit 200
Milliarden wir sind zusammen zu einer
Lösung gekommen das ist
mehr als erfreulich und bringt das Land
voran und gerade die Kollegen von der
FDP sind in weiten Weg gegangen und
davor habe ich Hochachtung für Lindner
ist es eine gesichtswarende Lösung
erstmal die Schulden Bremse aber
erscheint nur noch als pro forma
Instrument
die Schuldenbremse ist lediglich noch
eine Fassade denn einem wir werden im
kommenden Jahr 200 Milliarden Euro an
zusätzlichen Schulden haben durch diesen
Wirtschaft Stabilisierungsfonds der
jetzt aufgefüllt wird das sind sehr gute
Schulden sind notwendige Schulden aber
die Diskussion der Streit um die
Schuldenbremse zeigt doch dass sie
reformiert werden muss am Freitag wird
dem Bundestag noch einmal die gasumlage
verhandelt obwohl sie längst tot ist die
Idee mit der Gaspreis Bremse aber
beansprucht nun nach FDP und Grünen auch
die Union für sich wer hat es erfunden
wir haben sie vor Monaten schon dazu
aufgefordert dieses Instrument zu nutzen
allerdings die gaspreisbremse
funktioniert wie der klimafond den hält
die Union aber für verfassungswidrig
findet sie beim Gaspreis gut wogegen sie
beim Klima klagt
so zeigt diese Krise beides die
Widersprüche der Koalition wie auch die
der Opposition
[Musik]